[Music]
hey kaden what's up
hey dave how's it going good how can i
help
yeah so i am 21 and i'm about to
graduate college and it's always been a
dream of mine to own a mustang
and i wanted your opinion on how much i
could spend on that without messing up
any of my other financial goals
you have any money
yeah so i'm going to graduate debt-free
in december
and thanks to my parents and then i
worked through high school to help
contribute to that
i have about 13 000 in exhaust ira and
about 14 in the bank 14 grand
and you're graduating from
did you say college or high school
college with a degree in what
ag business
cool have you got a job
yeah so i have a job lined up starting
in september
and so that will be a full-time job as i
finish up school part-time good for you
how much will you be making
so that will be about 45 base salary and
then i'll go up from there with
commission and bonuses good for you well
done what are you driving now
uh so right now i have a subaru
crosstrek and
i'm using it for my internship and then
i would sell that to buy the mustang
yeah what's it worth
about 13 grand okay all right
well i love cars
so i get your dream okay
unless you're talking about the new
mustang which i think is ugly as crud
but anyway i love cars
uh the uh
and you know i got a weak spot for boats
i just got some mastercraft boats i
always wanted a mastercraft ski boat and
i've had mastercraft ski boats for years
uh and i just got the brand new ones
they're just amazing so i love things
with motors i'm a redneck i love them
okay so i'm with you
um
the uh but but what i have learned is is
that i want my dreams to be done in such
a way that they don't become a nightmare
is that okay
exactly which is kind of what you asked
you just said a different way i want to
do it i want to do it wisely is what you
asked
so what are you thinking you should do
what do you want to do
so what i want to do is i'll get a
company vehicle with this new job in
september and so i can use that for
personal use and so practicality doesn't
have to be a consideration okay and so i
would sell my current vehicle and then
i'm trying to figure out how much more i
can put on that and get you know newer
better faster
you know how that goes
okay so i mean you've looked at mustangs
you've been thinking about this what are
you thinking about
i'm thinking about 20 to 25 000 but to
me i've always been kind of a tight wad
and so that's that's a big number for me
okay
i think you're in range um the range
that we use is a you pay cash
and you'll be debt free when you do all
of this if i understood you're right
correct
yep
and b
you don't want vehicles things with
motors and wheels to add all together
because they all go down in value to be
more than half of your annual income
if you're making 45 and you have a car
that's worth 20
i mean that's okay it's not the end of
the world
i'm glad you didn't call me up and tell
me you wanted to lease a new one
yeah i knew i knew what you'd say to
that one good i'm glad saved us both a
lot of pain
so here's my thing about that
you've got the company car so this one's
going to be sitting around a whole bunch
isn't it it's just kind of a weekend
driver
essentially
yep yeah
so in that case it makes me less excited
you know you're not going to be driving
it all that much so to spend 20 000 i
would just look at your other goals you
said you had other financial goals right
you're probably wanting to buy a house
one day
might need to save up for a wedding one
day you have other things going on your
life you want to be able to invest 15
into retirement with your new job so i
would just factor all of those things in
before making this purchase i still
think it's a wise purchase based on the
parameters you set out but i would also
look at the opportunity cost of what my
other goals are and what my future looks
like yeah
so
here's the thing there's nothing
devastatingly stupid about what you're
talking about doing
but you are parking twenty thousand
dollars in something that's not going to
go anywhere
and it is most of your net worth
okay
so it would be okay
to delay the purchase of the mustang
since it is kind of a toy in a sense
here
a a year and let's see what a year
brings
and you might end up delaying it two
years let's see what two years brings
and that kind of thing i'm not saying
don't live your dreams not saying you've
always wanted to own a mustang that's
fine
now if you'll select
the particular mustang that you're going
to buy very carefully
uh in terms of mileage cleanliness and
the uniqueness of the particular car
with what it's got in it how it's built
all that kind of thing
that could ensure that you could resell
it quickly and easily if you ever wanted
to
say
fall in love and you wanted to buy a
house
with said queen more than you wanted
said car
and you can unload the car at that point
don't get too attached to this crap it's
car and right now it's not a great time
to buy a car so that's another reason to
wait and that 14 000 you have in cash
that sounds like it's your emergency
fund and so we need to save up outside
of that so that when you sell your
subaru you have the cash on hand with
that money to then purchase it in cash
yeah i'm probably waiting till spring
and let's have a little cooling off
period
and i might wait till the next spring
uh but but i think you're you know
you're on the right track and the ratios
we're giving you are there if it's a toy
pay cash for it never have more than 50
of your income tied up in things that go
down in value that have motors and
wheels and i got a lot of junk with
motors and wheels now because i'm kind
of i like you know
i like stuff that goes wooden wooden you
know i just do and so
uh but that's but it's a very very small
percentage of my world overall and that
helps me stay sane and wise and all of
those kinds of things